the New York Times is furious that
conservatives are reporting the news
they are demanding that the
Conservatives stop reporting the news
this is the New York Times newsroom and
there will be no journalism here we
examine the latest controversy and why
the latest times temper tantrum has gone
too far
even for fellow left-wing outlets like
the Washington Post and Politico then
Joe Biden's support collapses in a new
Monmouth University poll young people
are abandoning traditional values and
the PC left is furious over Dave
Chappelle's excellent new comedy special
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the New York Times has officially come
out against journalism this is perfect
this is just great is a temper tantrum
going through the entire newsroom of the
New York Times it exposes for once and
for all the hypocrisy of the mainstream
media and of the left and of
specifically the New York Times which is
the iconic newspaper in this country we
already knew they were hypocrites but
this they really just throw their cards
on the table no subtlety anymore we are
living in the age of Trump and he's
making them do it we'll get to that in a
second but first support for the michael
knowles show comes from our friends at
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans I live
in Los Angeles it is not easy to find a
home it's easy enough you find it you're
looking and it's like seven zillion
dollars and everyone's already bidding
on it and it's all just a disaster
fortunately I know that when I do find
the house of my dreams finding the right
mortgage will be easy because rocket
mortgage makes it easy I'm a millennial
I never learned to anything useful I
didn't learn how to balance a checkbook
I didn't learn any of the very complex
aspects of getting a mortgage
fortunately their mortgage experts over
Quicken Loans have their number-one goal
to make the home buying process smoother
for you they have industry-leading
online lending technology rocket
mortgages there with award-winning
client service and support every step of
the way you know buying a home is for
most people the most important financial
decision they will ever make in their
lives it's extremely complicated don't
go it alone go in there with the best
Quicken Loans is ranked the highest in
customer satisfaction for primary
mortgage origination nine years in a row
they're also ranked highest in mortgage
servicing five years in a row when you
work with them you get more than just a
loan because rocket mortgage is more
than just a lender get started online at
rocket mortgage.com slash Knolls cana
wles Equal Housing lender licensed in
all 50 states n MLS consumer access
story number 3030 rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans push button get mortgage
so the New York Times officially comes
out against journalism they don't do
this on page b7 or z10 they do it right
there on the front a 1 they are so
furious at president
right now that they are formally
objecting to journalism because here's
what happens the New York Times reports
on conservative figures conservative
politicians conservative media figures
sometimes on private conservatives and
private citizens that is apparently a
good thing really good when the New York
Times reports on conservatives now there
are conservatives who are reporting on
leftist New York Times reporters that is
very bad it's good when we do journalism
to conservatives bad when we do
journalism to leftists why is that
uh-huh just cuz because the New York
Times says so so we have to believe it
this is the article from the New York
Times begins quote Washington a loose
network of conservative operatives
allied with the White House is pursuing
what they say will be an aggressive
operation to discredit news
organizations deemed hostile to
President Trump by publicizing damaging
information about journalists it's the
latest step in a long-running effort by
mr. Trump and his allies to undercut the
influence of a legitimate news reporting
not that illegitimate news reporting
that all those conservatives are doing
but the legitimate news reporting how
can you tell what's a legitimate news
reporting well it's when the New York
Times does it
so when leftists do it when
conservatives report the news that is
illegitimate why because they're
conservative and only leftists are
supposed to report on the news now what
are they doing what is the damaging
information because when I read that I
thought you know that's a little it's a
little tricky it's a little crafty what
are they doing they're probably digging
through these reporters trash cans right
they're probably going in calling up
their ex-girlfriends and their ex-wives
ex-boyfriends I don't know I don't want
to be discriminatory or exclusive here
they're probably finding sex scandals
right they're probably going into their
personal lives because that might be a
little bit too far they do it to us the
left does at us all the time but look I
think that's there should be a
separation between public and private
maybe that is a little bit too far
except that's not what they're doing at
all do you know what they're doing the
shadowy group allied with the White
House discrediting real journalists all
they're doing is reading through the
juror
lists tweets they are lit they're just
combing the journalists public social
media profiles
The Times goes on but for people
familiar with the operation described
how it works
asserting that it has compiled dossier
of potentially embarrassing social media
posts and other public statements by
hundreds of people who work at some of
the country's most prominent news
organizations so they're reading the
journalists public statements and
journalists you will recall for their
job for a living make public statements
that's what they do so there so with the
shadowy group is doing is reading the
news and that is bad the New York Times
is furious because people are reading
the news okay reading the journalists
public pages public statements and then
they are posting about the journalists
public statements now how could the New
York time and this is this is so absurd
I'm surprised even the New York Times
could do this with a straight face but
how do they do it how are they able to
run this big story it's bad that
conservatives read and post about the
news that's more or less what the thesis
of this story's how can they do that
with a straight face listen to the
language that they use
The Times writes operatives have closely
examined more than a decade's worth of
public posts and statements by
journalists the people familiar with the
operation said you see it's not just
people reading the news and posting
about it it's an operation oh only a
fraction of what the network claims to
have uncovered has been made public so
let's stop right there
that isn't true it's all been made
public these are all public posts they
haven't uncovered and it's just there
it's it's it is uncovered in order for
something to be uncovered it has to be
covered in the first place but this
isn't covered in the first place
this is journalists whose job it is to
write things in public for a living
writing things in public and then these
people reading it and reposting it only
a fraction of what the network claims to
have been uncovered has been made public
the people said with more to be
disclosed as the 2020 election heats up
the research is said to extend to
members of journalists families ok now
Stella stop right there that's not good
I don't want people's families to get
dragged into this you know people have
private lives they private families they
I would really be upset if somebody were
started digging through my wife's stuff
I I wouldn't do it to somebody else or
someone's kids or son it's just ugly
it's wrong
that's the journalists or the fair game
their public figures public figures are
totally fair game but the private law
will hold on wait a second hold on wait
we got to finish that sentence because
the sentence in the New York Times it
goes on it says the research is to said
to extend to members of journalists
families who are active in politics as
well as liberal activists and other
political opponents of the President so
it the work of these shadowy right-wing
operatives isn't going into the families
private lives it's only covering the
family members who are politicians who
are public political activists who are
already fair game by the way the fact
that these journalists families are
active in politics is a scandal in
itself I get I mean I guess it's like if
it's a commentator or somebody somebody
who has an obvious political point of
view that they own up to you know let's
say it's somebody on this Sean Hannity
or so let's say if Sean Hannity's wife
were a congressman or a governor or
something that wouldn't be a scandal
because Hannity has a political point of
view or if it was banner if it were
Tucker if it were drew or if it were me
if if our relatives were in politics you
wouldn't say oh my gosh I'm shocked to
find out that this person holds a
conservative point of view because we're
open about our point of view but for
journalists who are purportedly
objective reporters to then we find out
their whole families are in politics
that is scandal reporters are supposed
to have objectivity reporters are not
supposed to be literally sleeping with
their subjects that
not good I mean this has been something
that we've criticized the left for for
so long
George Stephanopoulos spends his whole
career as a Democrat political operative
he is actually the communications
director for the Clinton White House and
then one day he puts on a different
color tie and he pretends to be an
objective reporter on Network News
what are you do what are you talking
about a B C this was the guy who
masterminded the Clinton propaganda
strategy you say that's just ridiculous
that is a scandal now the New York Times
has upset that more people are gonna be
exposed about that the own and and the
only people that this the shadowy group
is going after or the family members who
are already public figures in and of
themselves the New York Times whining
about this was so outrageous it was
actually too much even for the
Washington Post and for Politico both of
which are left-wing outlets here's what
the Washington Post wrote about it I
mean a really great coverage of it wopo
writes quote there is an incompatibility
in the Times story in the Saltzburg er
memo on one hand there is an attempt to
tour the motivations of the loose
network of conservative operatives quote
on the other hand there's a stubborn
admission that they have brought
actionable information to public
attention for decades now
representatives of the mainstream media
have answered conservative critiques by
imploring judge us by the work we
produce not by the fact that more than
90% of us are liberal democratic
mainstreamers cannot have it both ways
this is the key mainstreamers could not
have it both ways he goes on cut the
idol and unverifiable talk about
motivations if the tweets presented by a
loose network of conservative operatives
are racist or anti-semitic or otherwise
problematic take action if they're
nonsensical distractions ignore them
spot-on
at least this guy in the Washington Post
is holding his side the left-leaning in
some cases hard left so-called
journalists of the New York Times he's
holding them to their own standards
Politico same thing Politico has an
article out quote the headline why
journalists old tweets are fair game for
Trump New York Times editors don't
deserve special immunity from screwed
for bigoted speech totally right but
that's what they want the New York Times
wants one set of rules to apply to them
and then an entirely different set of
rules to apply to the right that's what
they do and the thin-skinned it the New
York Times is not just on the hard left
it's even on what you would call
formerly the center right now in this
case you call it the never Trump right
Politico started its piece about the New
York Times they started by quoting
Edward Armour oh the old journalist with
the cigarette he was portrayed by by
George Clooney in that movie good night
and good luck very left-wing journalist
and the line though is journalists don't
have thin skins they have no skins
journalists are very take things very
personally they're very sensitive and
the person exemplifying this over at the
New York Times is Bret Stevens who used
to be a right winger now I don't know I
guess he's center-left you would call
him now he's kind of a Hillary Clinton
guy at very anti Trump but so Brett
Stevens yesterday there was a story that
was going around Twitter that the New
York Times newsroom had bedbugs and you
know it's in New York
everyone gets bedbugs at some point in
New York it's just a it's a gross island
and it's very compact and there are
bedbugs and that's just the way it is so
I guess some of these bedbugs got into
the New York Times some guy makes a joke
this is an associate professor of media
at GW his name is David Karp and he
makes a joke on Twitter he says the
bedbugs are a metaphor the bedbugs are
Bret Stevens who's this sort of Center
centrist or Center left and now
columnist at the New York Times and I
don't know the professor could be
right-wing or left-wing I don't know
what he is the left wingers at who read
The Times don't like Stevens because
they say he's too right wing and the
right wingers don't like Stevens now
because he's too left-wing so that's
that's what he tweets that he makes a
joke about how Stevens is the bed bug
the tweet gets 9 likes and zero retweets
so basically nobody sees this tweet
within an hour
Brett Stevens emails this guy directly
and CC's the guy's boss on the email the
is what the email says quote I'm often
amazed about the things supposedly
decent people are prepared to say about
other people
people they've never met on Twitter I
think you've set a new standard I would
welcome the opportunity for you to come
to my home meet my wife and kids talk to
us for a few minutes and then call me a
bedbug to my face that would take some
genuine courage and intellectual
integrity on your part dude take a joke
good grief
some guy that no one's ever heard of
made a little joke on Twitter about a
public figure and you are not only can
you not take it not only you're inviting
the guy to your house around your all
this passive-aggressive email but you
copy the guy's boss on the email like
you're trying to get the guy fired
actually even MSNBC called out Brett
Stevens for this outrageous email this
outrageous attempt to get a media
professor fired there did it today
here's Stevens his answer I also copied
his Provost on the note people are upset
about this I want to be clear I had no
intention whatsoever to get him in any
kind of professional trouble but it is
the case at the New York Times and other
institutions that people should be aware
managers should be aware of the way in
which their people their professors or
journalists interact with the rest of
the world hold on hold on you say I had
no intention of getting this guy in
professional trouble I emailed his boss
to complain about him but I had no idea
I had no intention of getting him in
professional trouble but he should be in
professional trouble and I called his
boss that's what he's saying right he's
the but completely negates everything
that came before it in that statement
Bret Stevens this is a guy on top of the
world as one of the biggest microphones
in the world New York Times columnist
can't take a little joke from a media
professor that no one's ever heard of at
GW so he sees the guy's boss and
obviously tries to get him in trouble if
not fired probably tries to get him
fired too because if you get an email
like that from a guy as powerful as
Brett Stevens at the New York Times what
are you gonna you're not going to punish
the employee for it of course not it's a
joke this is what people despise about
the media the self
Arius it's not that we don't like
seriousness we don't want to be
frivolous and flippant all the time into
labor or anything like that
but we want people to be serious and not
self serious GK Chesterton said the
angels can fly because they can take
themselves lightly they're not always
taking themselves done seriously but
they can take themselves lightly and so
they can fly we hate self seriousness
you know this self seriousness in
journalism really began I think in
earnest when the newsrooms replaced all
the actual reporters with these over
credentialed elite young people so
journalism used to be a kind of
middle-class job you didn't really need
to go to college if you did you could go
to a journalism program get out go work
work as a reporter is very simple now
being over credentialed or not you know
being a beat reporter or something
that's fine if you want to be in
commentary if you want to pursue one
political point of view over another if
you have a vision of the world and
you're you're expounding on them
punditry or something like that's fine
for reporters though that's not fun you
see for reporters you need to just
pursue the facts that's it it's a simple
job typically it hasn't paid that well
it's a honorable job it's a simple job
you just do it and and now because we've
got these overly self-important people
who actually aren't that good at
journalism who aren't that good at
reporting they are just focusing on
themselves journalists reporters you are
not the great defenders of democracy you
are not defending democracy in darkness
you're not for serving our country
you're not even especially good at being
an arbiter of the truth or discerning
the truth write your story quit whining
do your job it's very simple I was at
the Praeger you dinner the other night
with micro micro had great advice that
he passed along from a mentor of his and
the advice was don't focus on how you're
doing focus on what you were doing focus
on the what not the how today
journalists are only worried about the
how
how do I look how do I sound how am I
being perceived how many times am I
being invited on television how are
people on Twitter talking about me how
did that guy tell that joke about that
bedbug ah they're not focused on the
what which is their job which is
reporting the facts do your job
focus on the what worry about what
you're doing let the how take care of
itself
speaking of thin-skinned by the way
there is an excellent Netflix special
out that you have to watch and critics
on both the left and the right are a
sailing this Netflix special which is
how you know that it's good it's how you
know that the comedian is hovering right
over the mark I'm talking about Dave
Chappelle's new Netflix special so
National Review which is conservative
publication gave this special a bad
review the review of it itself was not
very good but the the review talked
about how this special it took on too
many taboo subjects it said too many
taboo things no we can't laugh we can't
it's not funny now that's just natural
review that's fine on the Left virtually
every publication all the coverage of it
was saying that the special is awful
it's transphobic it's sexist its victim
blaming it's - all the PC terms all of
the PC jargon came out in these reviews
and Chappelle doesn't care Chapelle is
having none of it
he takes on every PC taboo in the
SPECIAL he takes on the me - movement he
takes on what he calls the alphabet
people LGBT queue LMNOP whatever he
takes on canceled culture here is just a
quick clip from the trailer to give you
an idea about how this show is going I
want to see if you can guess who it is
I'm doing an impression of alright let
me get into character yeah guess who it
is though okay here goes oh hey Durer
if you do anything wrong in your life
dull and I find out about it I'm gonna
try to take everything away from you and
I don't care what I find out could be
today tomorrow 15-20 years from now if I
find out you're finished
who's that that's you that's where the
audience ounds like to me
[Applause]
that's why I don't be coming out doing
comedy old Pam because young is the
worst mother because I've never tried to
entertain in my life just absolutely
this is spot on obviously there he's
taking on a canceled culture and he's
turning it on the audience in a really
brilliant way because he's talking about
something that is so relevant right now
which is that you know somebody told a
joke thirty years ago and you've got a
like ruin his life now take away his
career take away his house and banish
him to outer darkness where there's
wailing and gnashing of teeth but he's
also pointing out the hubris the self
seriousness the arrogance of the
audience not just the audience in that
room but all of us is the audience the
Twitter audience the social media
audience the Weehoo all we do is we wake
up in the morning say oh oh that was a
good sleep well time to get on the
internet and ruin everyone's life time
to get on the internet and judge people
oh yeah I got a busy day I don't even
know if I can fit in a cup of coffee
this morning because I have to judge
people all day for their private remarks
thirty years ago I'm not even judging
topics not even judging political issues
because that's not what people are
judging they're judging a joke that some
guy made in the 90s it has no bearing on
what it was happening right now or
political issues or cultural issues or
religious issues and and Chappelle is
just totally flipping on it oh you oh
you're you think it's Trump that I'm
making fun of because Trump he's the
worst thing in the world right no it's
you you're the worst thing in the world
it's really great I'm not gonna spoil
the rest of the show that's just one bit
in the trailer but there is great stuff
out there he does a bit on abortion that
is the funniest most incisive abortion
bit I've seen since louis c.k is a few
years ago Louie CK is another guy that
no one's allowed to mention he's now
been unperson because he had a bizarre
sexual history and proclivity he comes
up in the show I mean it's just terrific
Dave Chappelle doesn't care
Dave Chappelle is the honey badger and
the honey badger don't give a damn
the honey badger does not care Chappelle
is not in my estimation the great
living comedian the greatest living
comedian is Norm Macdonald but Chappelle
is up there Chappelle is pretty close
Dave Chappelle is not the greatest
living philosopher I don't look to him
for political commentary or cultural
commentary or something some comedians
do this George Carlin kind of became a
philosopher toward the end of his life
in the end of his career I can't stand
that I can't stand when comedians turn
their specials into philosophy Chappelle
doesn't do that Dave Chappelle isn't a
confessional comedian I hate
confessional comedy it's the worst where
it's just all me me me me that's not
what Dave Chappelle does Dave Chappelle
writes crafts and tells jokes that are
relevant that have bearing on the truth
that tell you something about the world
that most importantly make you laugh why
are his jokes funny why at a time when
there are so many clunker terrible
Netflix specials I mean Amy Schumer's
thing a few years ago it was unwatchable
not even just conservatives were saying
that because we don't like Amy Schumer
the left was saying this chummy was just
not funny at all the best example of
this was Nanette who was that Netflix
special that all of the elite
self-styled elite critics said oh it's
changed comedy it's unbelievable that
Nanette comedy special that came out a
couple years ago barely had any jokes in
it because what the way that she changed
comedy apparently was to turn comedy
into tragedy she said I'm not going to
tell jokes anymore I'm not gonna make
people laugh anymore this is the new
comedy it's not the new comedy it's
called the old tragedy they can't tell
jokes the left wasn't is not able to do
that particularly because they are
constrained by ideology and Dave
Chappelle is not constrained by ideology
he just isn't it's not like I agree with
Dave Chappelle on everything I don't
I've never talked to him I suspect he
and I don't agree on every single thing
but the reason why he can tell jokes
that make me laugh and I can laugh at
the jokes that he tells is because I do
my best not to be constrained by
ideology and he certainly is not
constrained by ideology this is a very
important political point because
etiology is different from philosophy
ideology is certainly different from
great religious traditions it's great
from revealed religious truth ideology
is the formalized narrow abridged
rationalized five bullet point manifesto
and doctrine that purports to describe
all of reality this is what Marxism is
is what communism is this is what
leftism is it's here are the five bullet
points that determine the world that
described the world the world is a
history of class conflict and there is a
science of history and at the end of it
will have a Marxist utopia that's it
that's that's what more so everything
that the left sees or that Marxists
would see is through that lens of class
struggle and that's it that's all it is
that is an ideology conservatives
sometimes are tempted toward ideology
particularly say libertarians have more
of an ideological viewpoint but
traditionally speaking conservatives
have resisted ideology if you can sum up
the whole world in five bullet points
then you probably don't know very much
about the world if that's your vision of
all of reality I don't need it because
that's be s ditching ideology doesn't
mean you don't stand for anything
doesn't mean you don't have any basis of
your belief that's not even possible
everybody's got to serve somebody every
belief every view of the world boils
down to some beliefs so for instance me
I'm Catholic Christians broadly speaking
believe in the Nicene Creed I believe in
God the Father Almighty maker of heaven
and earth or not right I recite that
Creed every Sunday but I actually recite
it in Latin so I don't really understand
it which I guess makes me even less
ideological that is what I believe I
believe that credo in Unum Deum you know
every Christian Church every actual
Christian Church recites that Creed that
is the Christian Creed that's what I
believe and everything else is fair game
it's why I don't get exercised over tax
rates changing so I don't lose my
mind over some new tariff policy I don't
okay then one policy could be better
than the other
whatever I'm open-minded because the
left punts on eternal questions such as
that such as the basis of reality the
basis of belief because they they punt
on those questions they basically have
embraced materialism or secularism
atheism they make a religious Idol out
of political ideology that becomes the
religion and as a result they can't
laugh if you if you make a joke about
transgenderism you say you know I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure that that
big giant burly guy over there who's got
a big beard and like face tattoos and
more muscles and I've ever seen him out
I'm pretty sure that guy is not a little
girl pretty sure if you just make that
objects aren't even a joke that's an
observation they won't laugh they won't
agree with you they won't grant you any
premise they will frown they will be
angry because you've contradicted what
more or less has become their religion
as a result they can't laugh I mean that
you know we laugh at things cuz they're
true
you know comedians are pointing out the
absurdities of life and so to use one
example if you say that giant burly dude
over there with his shaved head and a
big beard and you know it's like
chomping on chewing tobacco or something
he's not a cute little girl if you point
that out
that's funny people would would laugh at
that unless you're so constrained and
warped by ideology that you can't that
you can't even laugh at Dave Chappelle
but you should you will laugh go check
it out it's a really really great
special gotta get to some 20/20 news Joe
Biden is tanking in the polls we will
get to that in just one second we will
also we'll get to why Joe Biden is
tanking in the polls and why I was right
we'll get to the bigger story if at the
basis of that which is a new poll
showing that young Americans values have
radically changed they are radically
abandoning their traditional values but
first I gotta let you know to tune in
today 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
for our latest episode of the
conversation I will be there it is
featuring me I will be answering your
questions live on air my answers will
dazzl you they'll at least dazzle me and
then you'll be there which will be very
nice the episode is free to watch on
Facebook and YouTube
but only subscribers can ask the
questions so subscribe to daily wire and
get your questions answered by me
today at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
and join the conversation you got to go
to daily wire comm do it right now we'll
be right back with a lot more
we've got to look at 20/20 and poor old
Joe poor ol sleepy Joe is collapsing in
his support this new poll is coming out
from Monmouth University it has him down
13 points he is now in a statistical
dead heat in this poll with Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren now this is
the worst poll from so far other polls
still have him up a bit
but sauce in the latest poll so it might
not be an outlier might just be showing
us things to come this is not terribly
surprising for those of us who said that
Joe Biden would pretty much peak at the
very beginning and then kind of steadily
lose support so long as other candidates
were able to show that they had any
chance whatsoever of beating Donald
Trump even worse for Joe Biden here is
that his support is collapsing among
every single demographic so he's down
among whites blacks high school grads
college grads men women and voters over
50 especially bad for him is losing
voters over 50 and black voters because
those two groups are groups that he had
a pretty decent hold on among the
Democrats and you know if Democrats for
instance can't pick up any older voters
you know any voters over the age of 50
since I think the median gung-ho rabid
Democratic voter is like 11 that's why
they want to lower the voting age but if
they can't maintain some support among
black voters and voters over 50 they're
in serious trouble and Joe Biden is
showing weakness there as well why is
this happening
three reasons first one is Joe Biden is
obviously losing his marbles this is not
even to lob a bomb or to be mean or
cruel to Uncle Joe he's just old and
it's not to say that old older people
can't be President obviously President
Trump is not a spring chicken himself
but Biden seems to be declining mentally
and physically here's a recent video of
Joe Biden struggling to string a
sentence together even one coherent
sentence well talking about health care
policy we also have a mechanism to
control drug prices you know the it's
not what we're no longer using
chemical-based things that all this
thing
dealing with cancers and other issues
relating the immune system or bio are in
it they're very expensive and we should
set up a system as I proposed which I
will for if I'm elected president that
allows the folks at HHS and then the the
folks at health and the the Health
Department in the United States HHS to
be able to go out and bring them
together outside experts and make a
judgement when there's a patent being
sought by a drug company what that
patent what it's worth what the range is
what what on earth is going on now in
that video he looks like he's struggling
to come up with his thoughts either
that's because of permanent mental
decline or it's because he's really
tired and I'm willing to give him the
benefit of the doubt and say he's really
tired campaign trails are exhausting
I've been on presidential campaigns
before it is unbelievably physically
demanding any campaign not just
presidential but congressional races I
mean you run for dogcatcher it's a tough
thing to do and it takes a lot out of
you it even takes out a lot for young
men you have to be up to the physical
aspect of that job it actually gives you
a lot of respect just on a physical
basis for guys like Trump and Reagan you
know when Reagan was meeting Gorbachev
for the first time you got Reagan the
oldest president in American history at
that time and he was gonna go meet
Gorbachev outside he was gonna he was in
doors he was gonna go down the stairs
and meet Gorbachev outside in the winter
so Gorbachev gets out and he's wearing
this big heavy coat because it's winter
time Reagan ditches the coat he won't
wear the coat he comes out of the door
and hops down the stairs moves very
quickly down those stairs and he just
looked like a vigorous young man
meanwhile Gorbachev who was younger
looked like he was older looked like he
needed the coat looked like he was
moving more slowly and the optics matter
the images matter when you're talking
about the leader of the free world when
you're talking about any sort of
politician same thing with Trump I mean
Trump by all accounts you can love any
criticism of him that you want he's
reckless he's impetuous he doesn't read
he doesn't miss he all the all the
typical attacks against him the one
thing that no
not even his worst critic can say is
that he doesn't have energy I mean he
pretty much got the GOP nomination
because he contrasted his high energy
with jeb Bush's low-energy Trump is a
high energy guy he by all accounts
doesn't sleep very much every night he's
constantly working he's constantly
vigorous when he's not working he's out
schmoozing on the golf course he's just
kind of moving around and he's like sort
of a medical wonder because he doesn't
exercise he brags about how he doesn't
exercise he eats fast food and drinks
diet coke at this point he's probably
just so preserved by the chemicals that
he can move around he'll outlive us all
that matters
nobody thinks of Donald Trump is a
doddering old man because Donald Trump
has more energy than you do Ronald
Reagan had the same thing he was just a
vigorous guy who was riding horses all
the time while he was president and well
he was and after he was president it
wasn't even riding Western he was
writing English he was writing even a
more vigorous style of horse riding Joe
Biden doesn't have that any if he
doesn't have that now he's not gonna
have it in a year and he's not gonna
have it if he were ever elected
president that's that's just the first
problem going on with Joe Biden the
second problem is he didn't have many
marbles to lose to begin with because
he's always been kind of a doofus he
graduated toward the bottom of his law
school class he had to drop out of the
1988 presidential race because of that
he had to drop out because he lied about
his law school record and cuz he
plagiarized speeches he's always been
just kind of a doof a doofus 2008 he was
nothing he really didn't do very much
when he was in the Senate other than
that 94 crime bill which was a very good
crime bill actually and it's the one
thing in his career he really has to run
away from
so he's losing it he didn't have much to
lose to begin with and third voters
priorities and values are changing is
the most important part this is the the
biggest issue for Biden and for the
country Ernest Hemingway describes going
bankrupt
is it happening gradually then suddenly
that's what we're seeing here with the
changing values of this country
Biden represents an old guard I'm not
saying he's a moderate he's not a
moderate but he does represent something
a little older for instance he's
patriotic he at least pays lip service
to love of country and patriotism the
other Democrats
don't and this is it this is changing
this is a new thing they don't like the
country now you might say the Democrats
never like the country the left always
hated the country maybe but at least
they paid lip service to it at least
hypocrisy is the tribute that Vice pays
to virtue now they are openly
denigrating the country
Andy Cuomo Democratic governor of New
York says America was never that great
Barack Obama says I don't believe in
American exceptionalism I believed in it
the way the Greeks believed in Greek
exceptionalism you have other candidates
now saying America's hopelessly racist
hopelessly bigoted there's no there's no
way to ever redeem America you you have
elected Democratic politicians
presidential candidates openly
denigrating the American flag supporting
people who are protesting the American
flag which is not just a symbol of one
institution or one aspect of the country
it's a symbol of the whole country
the entire nation they're openly hostile
to American this reflects a broader
trend among younger voters they're just
following where their voters are going
in this election Millennials will rise
up to possibly match or nearly match
baby boomers as eligible voters now that
doesn't mean they're gonna come out and
vote at the same rates as Baby Boomers
young young Americans don't vote at the
same rates as older Americans so
probably the boomers are still going to
vote at a higher rate but they're there
slowly and steadily gradually then
suddenly taking control of the country
and the politicians that rely on them
for votes are paying attention that
spells trouble because Millennials are
not as patriotic as past generations
don't take my word for it it's not just
insinuation this is according to a new
poll out from Wall Street Journal New
York
I read Wall Street Journal and NBC which
shows American values are shifting
dramatically gradually then suddenly
this is from the from the article
patriotism religion and having children
rate lower among younger generations
than they did two decades ago and they
rate much lower twenty one years ago
they took this poll strong majorities of
Americans chose the principles of hard
work patriotism commitment to
religion and the goal of having children
as being the most important to them now
the good news is Millennials and Gen Z's
still value hard work they still like
that but their only other sacredly held
value is tolerance tolerance religion
patriotism even having children rape
much much lower this is a direct result
of losing religion st. Andrew Breitbart
the patron of Hollywood conservative
said politics is downstream of culture
and we know culture is downstream of
religion cult and culture are related
words what the culture worships defines
that culture and this problem goes all
the way to the foundation of society
religion because when they say tolerance
they don't really mean tolerance
tolerance is one of the most abused
words in the English language today this
started in the 1960s when the father of
the new Left Herbert Marcuse ax wrote an
essay called repressive tolerance in
which he said we can no longer tolerate
intolerance and so tolerance needs to
become intolerant this when we
conservatives joke about the the
so-called tolerant left which is always
attacking conservatives and shutting us
down for any of us kicked off campus in
some cases physically attacking us
they're obviously not being tolerant
they're being tolerant by this new
definition of Tolerance capital T it's
it's the the value of secular religion
what it really means is it's the value
of multiculturalism capital M and
cultural relativism capital letters
right they mean those ideas mean that
nothing is true objectively therefore
tolerance and hard work or all that we
can value the thing that's really
troubling about this too because look we
all like hard work at least we can all
agree that hard work is a good value
except in this case it spells trouble
because it means that we increasingly
only value things that have to do with
our will not with our intellect hard
work and tolerance our values of the
will you can just sort of will yourself
to do it grit your teeth and tolerate
stuff you don't like that's the good
version of Tolerance or grit your teeth
and tolerate only tolerant opinions and
don't tolerate the intolerant opinions
and kick them out of your campus but
you're still it's all about the
we'll it's not about actually thinking
this is true and beautiful this is
better than this
this is this is more accurate than this
this is objectively true it's just the
will same thing when it comes to hard
work hard work you just grit your teeth
and do it right not because of any
intellectual scheme or reason the scheme
of reason but you just will yourself to
do work religion patriotism or values of
the intellect you can't you can't even
really will yourself into it if the
intellect won't go with you you you
subscribe to a religion because you
think it's true because you think God
exists and he has a son named Jesus
Christ and he Christ instituted a church
and you go to Mass for that reason and
you he instituted sacraments and you
have those sacraments it's there is an
act of will obviously but it's part of
the intellect that comes along too same
thing with patriotism
you can't just will yourself into love
in your country you can't will yourself
into loving anything really you can go
through the motions but there has to be
intellectual assent at some point you
have to really love your country why do
I love my country because it's a great
country why do I love my parents because
they're great parents you know I mean
it's the same kind of thing it's the
same sort of filial piety I I will my
love obviously I enact my love of
country my patriotism but I
intellectually assent to that as well
and we have undercut our own confidence
in our faculties of reason nothing is
true when nothing can be believed this
radical skepticism you do you I'll do me
I can't ever tell you I can't impose my
views nothing stop stop being so judgy
these these kind of slogans these kind
of ideas are undercutting the basis of
our politics itself the basis of
self-government the basis of open debate
the basis of true tolerance when you
lose those things we're kind of living
on the fumes of them we're living right
now in the fumes of religion and
patriotism once that's gone we have no
reason to participate in our
institutions to have reasonable debate
to have open rhetoric to have open
discourse in this country when it just
becomes about the will then we will
assert our will on others you see the
left doing that increasingly they are
it's just all about willfulness and what
they want they're gonna get what they
want because they want it when they want
it and that is an unrecognizable country
when you when you stop loving your
country don't be surprised when you wake
up and the country looks very different
then you remember it that's our show we
got a lot more to get to but we will
just have to do it tomorrow tune into
our conversation that's coming up later
today in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
see you then
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy bori our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Dany D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup by Jesuit alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know people
are saying that America has never been
so divided and they can say that all
they want but it's completely and
utterly untrue what is true is that
there's never been a time at least not
in my memory when the elite
establishment has been rooting so hard
against the country that has given them
everything they have I'll show you what
I mean
on the Andrew Clavin show I'm late